you can watch her in her newest reality
series called paris in love please check
it out
before i was with carter i used to be
obsessed with going out i used to
remember
seeing my friends who were married or in
a serious relationship and
we'd have dinner and then of course i'd
want to go out after
and they'd be like no we're going to go
home i'd always think like oh they're so
boring i'm never going to be that way i
guess i'm now one of those boring people
who just like staying at home with their
future husband
i relate please welcome my old friend
and the phenomenal paris hilton
[Applause]
[Music]
and thank you for the intro you saying i
was literally crying backstage like oh
no
but that really means a lot to me how
just you introduced me i really
appreciate your words and your support
and just always how you are with me
thank you it means a lot
all right so
i love that clip because i have gone
through the same thing
and we were party girls
and i wondered will i ever grow out of
this
and now i've grown out of it so much i'm
like can i get back to that at all
like
but i love being more boring now as you
say or stay home or be that person who
does want to go home
after dinner
that is genuine to me
what is it for you exactly what you just
said now
which you know i'm so excited to start
this next phase and have a family
because i've lived a full life like
i've lived at all i've had so much fun
i've went to more parties than people do
in many lifetimes
and now i'm so happy to find someone
where i don't even want to go out like i
just want to be with him it alone i'm at
home because before i was kind of always
looking for someone and now that i found
my someone it's like i just want to be
with him all the time
i mean how wonderful is that
it is
it's the best feeling did you ever think
that that was gonna land because i was
so wild and hedonistic and always like
chasing the high of the fun i wanted to
go to every concert like i was
unstoppable i had a voracious
like
incurable appetite for fun
me too i called it club itis
[Laughter]
i was cured of my club itis by love i
and i like by kids it just it really
changed me and i don't think being grown
up is overrated though
i i feel like i'm getting calmer
wiser better
what is it for you
i feel that i've changed so much i've
grown so much just after doing my
documentary before that i didn't really
know who i was
and over the past couple years just
learning so much realizing how strong i
am and
now finding love i've just never been in
a better place in my life and
i don't know i'm just so excited for
what the future
is holding
[Music]
you